as a hint i'll take the determinant of a
very similar 2 by 2 matrix so we want to
figure out the determinant of this
matrix and we can denote it by the
determinant of the 2 by 2 matrix 5
negative 1 and 4
and the definition of a determinant of a
2 by 2 matrix like this is we can first
take this diagonal 5 times 4 so let me
write that down it's going to be 5 this
is going to be equal to 5 times four
minus
minus the product of this diagonal
minus the product of that diagonal so
minus
three times
three times negative one
three times negative one so what does
this give us
so five times four is twenty
and then three times negative one would
be negative three this is negative three
but then we're subtracting negative 3
which would make it adding a positive 3.
so 20 plus 3. and so the determinant of
this matrix ready for the drum roll is
20 plus 3 is
23.